our series a more perfect evening aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us and
that principle was embodied by Rosa
Parks whose actions inspired the civil
rights movement
she was arrested 64 years ago this week
for not giving up her seat to a white
passenger on a bus in Montgomery Alabama
CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller is at the Library of
Congress in Washington DC where a new
exhibit is detailing parks life
good morning Michelle what can people
see there they can see a whole lot we
can tell you you know we grew up with
that story right it was told to us in
school parents shared it with us
but this exhibit give us us a full
picture of her life her decade of
activism before that event her struggle
and triumph after it through her
writings memorabilia and 2,500
photographs the Library of Congress is
showing us the Rosa Parks was no
accidental activist few people in this
world have launched a revolution sitting
down that day miss parks said this is it
enough is enough enough is enough for
that reason librarian of Congress Carla
Hayden is giving Rosa Parks a closer
look what do you want to show me first
the impact of her family history Hayden
says the exhibit Rosa Parks in her own
words reveals a granddaughter of slaves
from teen rebel defying injustice to
n-double-a-cp leader to Civil Rights
icon you see in her own handwriting
her thoughts her inner feelings and she
had such poetry there is just so much
hurt Adrian Cannon curated the
collection which contains more than
7,000 of parks writings I had been
pushed around all my life and I felt at
this moment I couldn't take it anymore
but Cannon says while writing often on
recycled paper parts found her voice
strategizing against segregation was
mrs. parks plan all along to do
things she could in order to get
equality for African Americans Fred gray
was fresh out of law school in 1954 when
he worked with parks and the
n-double-a-cp
to counsel blacks jailed under
segregation laws my first civil rights
case was Claudette Coghlan the 15 year
old girl who Oh March 2nd 1955 did the
same thing that Rosa Parks did but did
it nine months before Colvin's case may
have set an example but not the stage
that came on December 1st 1955 Oh Jane
Gunther then pregnant military wife is
the only other person to admit she was
there all of a sudden there was a tall
man standing in front of me I stood up
and said God she can have my seed and
when I said that he pushed his knees
into my knees and said when she realized
years later what she witnessed she
called to meet Parks did she remember
you no she didn't remember me I said the
story about the tall man and she
instantly said you were there you were
there Parks his conviction launched the
year-long bus boycott in Montgomery they
knew that there would be some event that
would allow them to put the plans in
action Alabama a charismatic new
preacher that had come to town didn't
hurt either at present we are in the
midst of a protest protests sparked by a
woman who never rested who believed the
struggle continues and now everyone can
see the impact of both her actions and
words her writings are right here with
Thomas Jefferson with Thurgood Marshall
with all of these other people her
writings are right here and so is her
family Bible one of the many dresses
that she made and the Presidential Medal
of Freedom she was awarded back at the
White House in nineteen
96 this exhibit opens today it's free to
the public and it's well worth a visit
Anthony and I really really want to go
Michelle thank you very much what no
accidental activist no not at all